We had no competition.
Hooters had no competition back in 1983 when it was developed.
We were the first of our kind.
Casual dining really was just, sort of, getting started back then,...
...and there was nothing in the sports theme area that we were sort of in.
I mean, you had mom and pops at their own restaurants and everything,...
...but it didn't have the sex appeal,...
...it didn't have the cold beer.
There just wasn't a lot of options for people to choose from.
And it does, sort of, what's held true today.
We've got a lot more competition.
But it, sort of, was unique to people's taste.
And I think they relate well.
They have really enjoyed it because we're around, going on 30 years sort of.
Right now, if you're gonna start a new business, be very prepared.
Be very patient.
And treat whatever customers you start out with very well...
...because hopefully, you'll have those customers when you're 5 years, 10 years, 15 years.
So, just be true to yourself and take care of the first customers you get...
...because hopefully they'll stay around with you.
Be patient.